all right welcome to the 14th PHP
tutorial this tutorial we're going to be
discussing the for each loop one of my
favorite loops I probably this probably
like the most useful loop in the work
very closely related to the for loop in
Python which probably why i like it just
reminds me of pod one so with that the
syntax for this and like that kind of
structure is the same as the if in the
while and yellow for loop you just say
for each parameters and then curly
braces and so what we want to do is
we're going to do for each needle save
for each nieto array as I guess we'll
say type or something it's really it's
like you know for each gender or
something but we'll just say type and
then within their you've got these
peoples names we want to echo um tight
actually part of that we want to just
echo type will break that or semicolon
and let's just run this for now
hopefully we don't have any hairs we
haven't run anything since we made this
multi-dimensional array hiring me in
trouble brawley oh no we got it that's
great I'm excited so as you can see
we've got you know the categories male
and female but they're sitting next to
each other I mean they're like bam bam
so what we'd really like to do is have
mail on top of female again and but
really we're going to want some spacing
in between them as well we don't want
the males and females getting too close
so what we're going to do is um we'll
just a
and what's the pen like two breaks right
Oh space them apart so we'll save that
and run it and sure enough there they
are spaced apart but now we want to get
the names like let's get the names like
uh people within these categories how do
we do this well let's make another for
loop for each to be exact so now after
we echo the type and we break for each
type now we want to do for each and will
say we'll call this or for each of the
names and we'll just say for and we'll
call them and we'll just a name like
that's the variable will assign to these
things now what we want to do is echo
just the name and then will append
another break otherwise the names will
be like all jumbled up so right and
let's say that and run that run and now
you can see where we've got mail we got
the list of the males and the female
this clearly structure it's a little
pull off so let's fix this up a little
bit so first of all what we're going to
want to do let's just make a single
break here and we'll make a single break
there let's go ahead and also make some
strong tags for the category strong type
and then here will close the strong tag
under strong so that a bold male and
female and then we'll run we'll just
break list all the names with breaks and
then after this like this'll since this
is like the end of all of the names
after we've listed all the names let's
actually echo one more break and if you
can't visualize it in your head you're
about to see why but the reason for that
will be so we break and have a nice
comfy space between the mail list and
the female
so we'll save that and run it and horse
error probably forgot a semicolon
somewhere I no semicolon you instead it
was the append there we go pull start
again refresh okay sure enough there we
go we've got our two grooves bold male
the list email the list so hopefully now
that you're starting to slowly
understand the use of putting things
together